THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY IS
BEGINNING. RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
GOING TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
PRIOR TO GETTING QUORUM. BUT I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE ARE
MEETING IN ROOM 2200. I'M HOPING
THAT ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN,
COME TO ROOM 2200. AS OF NOW, WE
ALREADY HAVE AUTHORS LINED UP,
AND WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS ON THE
CALENDAR TODAY. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ANNOUNCEMENT NUMBER ONE IS AB
667 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN HAS BEEN PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR FROM TODAY'S
CALENDAR, AND WE HAVE THREE
BILLS AB 2018 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ IS AB 1788 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AND AB 2759
PETRIE-NORRIS ARE ON CONSENT.
LOOKING LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE'RE GOOD. THE NUMBERS WRONG.
SORRY THAT WAS MINE, I HAVE THAT
IS IT A DIFFERENT MARK? SORRY.
1788 IS NOT. IT'S 20 AB 2621.
THAT WAS MY. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE
GOING TO RESTATE THIS. FOR
CLARIFICATION AGAIN, WE HAVE
THREE BILLS ON CONSENT AB 2018
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AB
2621 BY QUIRK-SILVA Ó BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND AB
2759 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS ARE ALL ON
CONSENT, I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE A ROLL
CALL TO SEE IF WE HAVE QUORUM.
WAHAB HERE. WAHAB HERE. SATO
HERE. SATO HERE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE. SKINNER WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE QUORUM. AND
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH OUR
VERY FIRST BILL. MAYBE THE
SECOND. YEAH. OKAY. WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO SKIP OVER TO
AB 2120 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
DO WE HAVE. YEAH. WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO START WITH AB
2018 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ, THAT'S ON 797977. WHY
DON'T WE JUST START WITH THIS,
OKAY. WE CAN WE? WHY DO YOU HAVE
A QUORUM? WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
OH WE DO? YEAH LET'S LET'S HAVE
A MOTION FOR CONSENT. SO MOVED.
THANK YOU. LET'S CALL A ROLL
CALL. VOTE ROB. HI, WAHAB. AYE,
SATO. AYE. SATO. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER WIENER.
AND I APOLOGIZE COMPLETELY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WE DON'T DO
THIS THE WAY THE ASSEMBLY DOES
IT. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU
SPEAK FROM HERE AND OUR
WITNESSES. YOU'RE GOING TO COME
TO THE LECTERN. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN, JUST FOR ANNOUNCEMENTS,
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT EACH
LEAD WITNESS HAS ROUGHLY TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK, BOTH IN
OPPOSITION AND IN SUPPORT. AND
ALL OF THE METOOS WE JUST ASK
THAT YOU STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. WE LIKE TO GO
THROUGH THIS PRETTY QUICKLY. SO
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 977, WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE PENALTY FOR
COMMITTING ASSAULT AND BATTERY
AGAINST HEALTH CARE WORKERS
INSIDE THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE THOSE
PENALTIES EQUAL TO THE PENALTIES
FOR ASSAULT AND BATTERY
COMMITTED OUTSIDE OF THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED
A HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE. THESE WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES CONTRIBUTES TO THE
LACK OF ACCESS, HIGH COST OF
CARE AND HEALTH CARE QUALITY AND
PATIENT OUTCOMES. WHILE THE
STATE HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS, ADDRESSING WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE MUST BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO MAINTAIN AND RECRUIT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS. DESPITE
YEARS OF HOSPITALS ADOPTING
PLANS TO PREVENT WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE, REPORTED INCIDENTS
HAVE NOT DECREASED, ACCORDING TO
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS, 85% OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS BELIEVE
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS HAS
INCREASED OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS, WITH OVER TWO THIRDS OF
THE EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN REPORTED
ASSAULTED BEING ASSAULTED IN THE
PAST YEAR ALONE. ONE STUDY
ESTIMATED THAT A HEALTH CARE
WORKER CAN EXPECT TO BE
THREATENED AT LEAST FOUR TIMES
AND ASSAULTED AT LEAST ONCE PER
YEAR. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT STAFF WHO
ARE EXPOSED TO WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE CAN SUFFER FROM
BURNOUT, TRAUMATIC STRESS AND
COMPASSION FATIGUE. FOR EXAMPLE,
ONE THIRD OF EMERGENCY NURSES
HAVE CONSIDERED LEAVING DUE TO
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE. AGAIN, THESE
ISSUES ALSO AFFECT HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND TREATMENT OUTCOMES.
SINCE MANY HEALTH CARE WORKERS
BECOME LESS PRODUCTIVE, HAVE
INCREASED ABSENTEEISM, AND HAVE
BEEN EVEN LEAVE THE PROFESSION,
OR EVEN LEAVING THE PROFESSION.
BEFORE I PASS IT TO MY WITNESS,
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SHARE THAT
AS A FIRST RESPONDER FOR OVER 30
YEARS, I HAVE PERSONALLY
WITNESSED ASSAULTS ON STAFF AND
EVEN AND EVEN BEEN PHYSICALLY
RESTRAINED BY ASSAULTERS. AND
ALSO MY DAUGHTER DESIREE IS A
HEALTH WORKER, A RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIAN, AND SHE HAS ALSO
BEEN A VICTIM OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE IN THE PAST TWO MONTHS.
THIS VIOLENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE
FOR MANY OF THE HEALTH CARE
HEROES THEY VIEWED WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE AS JUST PART OF THE
JOB. AS A RESULT, ONLY 3% OF
ASSAULTS RESULT IN PRESS
CHARGES, ACCORDING TO AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS,
THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE THE
NOTION THAT WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
IS AN INHERENT PART OF WORKING
ON THE JOB IN A HOSPITAL
SETTING, AND ENCOURAGE THEM TO
REPORT INCIDENTS. WE ALREADY
HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
PROTECTING OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS,
SUCH AS FIREFIGHTERS, POLICE
OFFICERS, EMTS AND PARAMEDICS.
OUR WORKERS IN THE HOSPITAL
DESERVE THE SAME PROTECTION BY
ESTABLISHING PARITY BETWEEN THE
PENALTIES FOR ASSAULT AND
BATTERY AGAINST AN EMERGENCY
WORKER, BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE HOSPITAL. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE WORKERS WITH RESPECT
THEY DESERVE WHILE PROTECTING
THEM FROM WORKPLACE VIOLENCE.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ARE
JONATHAN DEROSE, CHIEF NURSE
EXECUTIVE OF THE EDEN MEDICAL
CENTER, AND DOCTOR ANNA YAP, AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AT THE UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER, WITH ME TO
ALSO PROVIDE AN ANSWER. ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS CHRISTIAN
COMENZÓ FROM THE SACRAMENTO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU CAN,
PRESENT AND YOU HAVE ROUGHLY TWO
MINUTES. GREAT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JONATHAN
JUDY DELROSARIO. I'M THE HERE ON
BEHALF OF SUTTER HEALTH TO
SUPPORT AB 977. I'M THE CHIEF
NURSE EXECUTIVE AT SUTTER EDEN
MEDICAL CENTER IN CASTRO VALLEY
AND HAVE BEEN A NURSE FOR 26
YEARS, 17 OF THOSE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, DESPITE STAFFING
WITH INCREASED SECURITY
PERSONNEL, IMPLEMENTING OUR CARE
COVENANT, OUTLINING BEHAVIORAL
EXPECTATIONS AND PROVIDING BOTH
DIDACTIC AND HANDS ON TRAINING
TO OUR EMPLOYEES, WE CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH ACTS OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST OUR STAFF. I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE A FEW EXAMPLES OF THOSE
THAT HAVE OCCURRED, THAT
SUPPORTS THE NEED FOR THIS BILL.
DURING A BUSY DAY, A WAITING
PATIENT IN THE HALLWAY STUCK HIS
FOOT OUT AND KICKED A STAFF
MEMBER IN THE LEG, CAUSING THE
STAFF MEMBER TO STUMBLE. THE
PATIENT COMPLAINED THAT HE WAS
TIRED OF WAITING AND HE HAD NO
UNDERLYING CONDITION OR REASON
THAT WOULD HAVE CAUSED HIM TO
BEHAVE IN THIS MANNER. A
PATIENT'S SISTER WAS ANNOYED
THAT THEIR ED VISIT FOR A
NON-CRITICAL ISSUE WAS TAKING
TOO LONG. AS THE REGISTRATION
CLERK WAS TRYING TO COMPLETE HER
DUTIES, THE SISTER BEGAN YELLING
AT THE CLERK, SPAT IN HER FACE,
AND ATTEMPTED TO GET PHYSICAL
WITH THE CLERK BEFORE OTHER
STAFF HAD TO INTERVENE. A
PATIENT ARRIVED IN TRIAGE AND
DID NOT PROVIDE OR DID NOT
SCREEN POSITIVE FOR VIOLENCE
RISK COMING OUT OF THE BATHROOM,
HE ANNOUNCED TO THE ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT HE HAD OBTAINED
THE URINE SAMPLE AS REQUESTED,
AND THEN PROCEEDED TO TOSS HIS
URINAL INTO THE NURSE'S STATION,
HITTING A STAFF MEMBER AND
SPLASHING OTHER STAFF AND
EQUIPMENT WITH URINE. THERE WAS
NO UNDERLYING REASON THAT WE
COULD ASCERTAIN FOR HIM TO DO
THIS, AND HE LAUGHED ON HIS WAY
BACK TO HIS ROOM. TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE, IT HAS BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE, BOTH IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALAMEDA COUNTIES.
A STAFF ARE OFTEN DISCOURAGED
FROM PRESSING CHARGES AGAINST
PATIENTS, EVEN WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
PHYSICALLY HARMED, AND THE
REASON OFTEN CENTERS ABOUT
THERE'S TOO MUCH EFFORT FOR
MINIMAL RESULTS, EVEN IF THEY'RE
FOUND GUILTY OF THE CRIME. I ASK
YOU TO PASS AB 977 TO ENSURE
THAT OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
STAFF HAVE THE SAME PROTECTION
AND PEACE OF MIND THAT SOMEONE
WHO COMMITS ASSAULT OR BATTERY
WILL FACE THE SAME PENALTIES
THAT ALREADY EXIST FOR THOSE
OUTSIDE OF THE HOSPITAL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, AND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. I'M DOCTOR ANNA
YAP, A BOARD CERTIFIED EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN SERVING THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY AT THE UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER AND AT THE
VETERANS MEDICAL CENTER. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
WHO IS CO-SPONSORING ASSEMBLY
BILL 977. I'VE BEEN PUNCHED,
SLAPPED, KICKED, SPIT ON, AND
VERBALLY HARASSED AT WORK. AND
THAT'S NOT A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE.
WHILE TRAINING IN LOS ANGELES, I
HAD KHÓ RESIDENTS WHO HAD GUNS
AND KNIVES PULLED ON THEM BY
PATIENTS. MY COLLEAGUE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, WHILE 37 WEEKS
PREGNANT, WAS TACKLED TO THE
GROUND BY A PATIENT'S FAMILY
MEMBER. ANOTHER PHYSICIAN IN SAN
DIEGO TOLD ME ABOUT HER. E.R.
NURSES WERE ONE OF THEM WAS
KNOCKED TO THE GROUND AND BEATEN
SO HARD ON HARD ON THE CHEST
THAT THEY HAD TO HAVE SURGERY.
AND ANOTHER NURSE WAS SLAMMED
INTO SO HARD BY A PATIENT IN
THEIR WHEELCHAIR THAT HER FINGER
WAS AMPUTATED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WHEN A PATIENT
REALIZED I WAS ASIAN, HE YELLED
RACIAL SLURS AND INSULTS AT ME
AND THREW A USED URINAL AT ME.
AND AS HE HAD AN ABSCESS I
NEEDED TO DRAIN, I ACTUALLY
NEEDED A SECURITY GUARD WITH ME
THE WHOLE TIME WHILE I WAS DOING
THE PROCEDURE. SCARED THAT HE
WOULD GRAB THE SCALPEL FROM ME
AND STAB ME. DESPITE IT ALL, WE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS RARELY
IF EVER, REPORT ATTEMPTED OR
SUCCESSFUL ATTEMPTS BY PATIENTS
OR THEIR FAMILIES. WE ARE
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE TO
WANTING TO CARE FOR OUR
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AND VIEW
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE AS A PART OF
OUR JOB. HOWEVER, THERE'S ALSO
THE BELIEF THAT NOTHING WILL BE
DONE IF WE TRY TO REPORT, AND
WE'RE OFTENTIMES DISCOURAGED
FROM REPORTING BECAUSE IT'S TOO
MUCH WORK OR IT'S NOT WORTH IT,
WHICH IS PERPETUATED BY LAWS AND
POLICIES, SOME OF WHICH THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO CORRECT. AT
THE END OF THE DAY, IT IS UNFAIR
THAT IN THE ESPECIALLY UNSAFE
ENVIRONMENT OF THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT, WE GET LESS
PROTECTIONS THAN IF WE WERE
ASSAULTED BY SOMEBODY WHILE ON
THE STREETS. EMERGENCY
PROFESSIONALS ARE INCREDIBLY
BURNT OUT, PROMOTING A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO TREAT OUR COMMUNITIES
WILL ENSURE THE WELL-BEING OF
BOTH PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS.
PROTECT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS BY VOTING YES ON
ASSEMBLY BILL 977. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY MEET
LEAD OPPOSITION? LET'S GO WITH
LEAD OPPOSITION TWO MINUTES.
LEAD OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ALICIA
BENAVIDEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 977, WE AGREE
THAT DOCTORS, NURSES AND OTHER
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES HAVE A RIGHT
TO DO THEIR JOBS WITHOUT BEING
HARMED. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
RISK OF HARM IS SPECIFIC
CHALLENGES POSED TO HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, AND FORTUNATELY, AB 977
WOULD NOT PREVENT OR EVEN REDUCE
HARMFUL CONDUCT. INSTEAD, THE
BILL INCREASES THE POSSIBILITY
OF PUNISHMENT FOR OFFENSES THAT
ARE COMMITTED PRIMARILY BY
INDIVIDUALS BROUGHT INTO
HOSPITALS WHILE IN CRISIS.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY COVERS THE
SITUATIONS TARGETED IN THE BILL,
AND CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
ASSAULTIVE CONDUCT RANGE FROM
MISDEMEANOR TO FELONY
CONVICTIONS. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THERE IS CURRENT ADEQUATE
EVIDENCE TO INDICATE THAT THE
CURRENT LAWS AND SENTENCING
STRUCTURE ARE INSUFFICIENT, AND
FOR THESE REASONS, WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. LIKE
EMERGENCY ROOM STAFF, THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER STAFF WORKS WITH
DISTRAUGHT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
OFTEN MENTALLY UNSTABLE, AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE WORRIED AND
SCARED. WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR THOSE WHO WORK IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. MY OWN NIECE IS AN
EMERGENCY ROOM DOC. HOWEVER,
KPDA IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. WE
AND YOU KNOW THAT ENHANCED
SENTENCING DOES NOT DETER BAD
BEHAVIOR OR ENSURE SAFETY. I'M
VERY CONCERNED AT THE TESTIMONY
THAT STAFF IS DISCOURAGED FROM
TESTIFYING OR FILING COMPLAINTS.
THIS LAW ISN'T GOING TO FIX
THAT. THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
PROBLEM. THERE IS EXISTING LAW,
AS MY COMPATRIOT JUST TALKED
ABOUT. WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM AND ADDRESS THEM
DIRECTLY, NOT AFTER THE FACT.
WITH JAIL SENTENCES. THIS
PROBLEM HAS BEEN STUDIED BY MANY
RESEARCHERS. THE PROBLEM IS
STRUCTURAL ERS ARE A FAULTY
SAFETY NET FOR HOLES IN THE REST
OF THE SAFETY NETS. MORE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUFFERING IN
PAIN DEVASTATING PROGNOSIS,
UNFAMILIAR CROWDED SURROUNDINGS
AND MIND AND MOOD ALTERING
MEDICATIONS AND DRUGS. THEY ARE
MORE MORE OFTEN DEALING WITH
EXTREMELY LOUD, LOUD, LOUD AREAS
AND, LOUD CRIES OF PEOPLE IN
PAIN OR FEAR. THE EXAMPLES THAT
YOU HEARD ARE PEOPLE WHERE IT IS
REPORTED THAT FOR NO REASON,
THIS PERSON SLAMMED IN A
WHEELCHAIR OR KICKED SOMEONE. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT PERSON'S HEAD. AND LIKELY
THERE IS A MENTALLY, A MENTAL
CONCERN. AT THE SAME TIME,
PHYSICIAN AND NURSE HOURS ARE
BEING CUT AS PRIVATE EQUITY
TAKES OVER MANY HOSPITALS AND
TRIES TO WRING OUT PROFITS. THE
RESEARCHERS, TO INCLUDE THE
FEDERAL OSHA INCLUDE. FEDERAL
OSHA HAS COMPREHENSIVE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION GUIDELINES BASED ON
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES AND
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK. THERE ARE
MANY OPTIONS TO REDUCE ER
VIOLENCE ISSUES THAT DO NOT
INVOLVE PUTTING PEOPLE IN CAGES.
WE URGE YOUR NO VOTE ON AB 977.
THANK YOU. CAN WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO SPEAK FOR ME TO BOTH IN
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING. VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING OVER
400 HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
IN CALIFORNIA. PROUD CO-SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS, ALFREDO
MEDINA HERE ON BEHALF OF
CEDARS-SINAI MEDICAL GROUP IN
SUPPORT. STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS FRED
NOWHERE, REPRESENTING STANFORD
HOSPITAL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DEANNA, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND LA DEFENSA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
VICTORIA RODRIGUEZ WITH NIELSEN
MERKSAMER ON BEHALF OF YOLO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING.
JONATHAN CLAY, ON BEHALF OF
SCRIPPS HEALTH AND USC KECK
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE, IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. GRACE KOPLAN, ON BEHALF
OF PROVIDENCE HEALTH AND SUPPORT
KRISTIN SCHLUSSEL WITH THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND THEN
HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE. VANESSA KHN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS HERE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, JARED
MOSS, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENTS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
SENATOR SATO. ALL RIGHT. FIRST,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL. IT IS LONG
OVERDUE, THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
IS NOT NEW, BUT IT'S GETTING
WORSE, ANYBODY WHO HAS SEEN IT
FIRSTHAND, CAN TELL YOU THAT IT
IS NOT JUST PERPETRATED BY
PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING MENTAL
BREAKDOWNS. IT IS PERPETRATED BY
PEOPLE WHO ARE BULLIES, WHO
EXPECT TO BE TREATED FIRST
INSTEAD OF THE PERSON THAT
WALKED IN AFTER THEM, BECAUSE
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND A TRIAGE
SYSTEM, AND THEY ARE, ATTACKING
DEFENSELESS PEOPLE, IN THEIR
WORKPLACE. WE HAVE WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE LAWS, WE ALSO HAVE LAWS
THAT, WHEN SOMEBODY IS A HAVING
A MENTAL ISSUE, THERE ARE
ALLOWANCES FOR THAT, BUT THIS
SPANS THE ENTIRE SECTOR OF, THE
PEOPLE WHETHER, YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER THEIR RACE, GENDER OR
ETHNICITY, ALL THOSE THINGS, IT
DOESN'T MATTER. THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DOING THIS ARE DOING IT
BECAUSE THEY'RE MAD AND THEY CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT, AND THEY NEED
TO STOP BEING GETTING THEY NEED
TO STOP BEING ALLOWED TO GET
AWAY WITH IT, IF CURRENT LAWS,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S, THERE IS A
COMMENT THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO
PREVENT IT, YES, IT WILL,
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHOSE ANGER, THEY ALLOW
TO LET FLY BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR IT. HOWEVER,
WHEN THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES AND
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES LIKE THIS
SHOULD BE, THEN, THAT'S A WAY
FOR THEM TO SELF CHECK
THEMSELVES, BEFORE THEY GET INTO
THE CONFRONTATION THAT LEADS TO
THEM GETTING ARRESTED BECAUSE,
THAT'S THE PART THAT PEOPLE
DON'T WANT. BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
IF WE'RE GOING TO, TO, NOT GIVE
THAT CONSEQUENCE FOR THEM, WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
BATTERIES TAKE PLACE, I, I KNOW
PERSONALLY, A NURSE THAT IS WAS
DISABLED. SHE WAS ATTACKED,
THROWN TO THE GROUND AND
DISABLED. SHE HAD A HEAD INJURY
AND SHE COULD NEVER GO BACK TO
WORK. SHE COULD NEVER GO BACK TO
WORK. AND THE PERSON THAT DID
THAT, THERE WAS NOTHING MENTALLY
WRONG WITH THEM. HE WAS JUST MAD
. AND SO ENOUGH WITH THE EXCUSE
MAKING. IT'S TIME TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BAD
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
TO GO TO JAIL FOR WHAT THEY CAN
DO IS SIT THERE, BE A GOOD
PATIENT, AND COOPERATE WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO HELP
THEM. FOR PETE'S SAKE, STOP
MAKING EXCUSES IS A GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU, AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT. AND I MOVE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT, ANY OTHER
MEMBERS? SENATOR SKINNER? EXCUSE
ME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
GOT FROG IN MY THROAT THIS
MORNING. SOUNDS LIKE COUGHING.
LIKE YOU. SAME THING. ANYWAY I
APPRECIATE WHY YOU BROUGHT THE
BILL, AND I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORTERS INDICATION THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE THIS LAW FOR EMTS
AND SUCH WHO ARE WHEN THEY'RE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY VERSUS THE
CIRCUMSTANCE IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM. HOWEVER IT'S LIKE SO MANY
THINGS. MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE
THOUGHT MORE WHEN WE PASSED THAT
ORIGINAL ONE, BUT BECAUSE WE
HAVE ONE, ONE, YOU KNOW, ONE
STATUTE AND ONE CIRCUMSTANCE
DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN WE
SHOULD APPLY IT EVERYWHERE. AND
I. KNOW ONE WHO'S IN A HOSPITAL
SETTING SHOULD I MEAN, THEY
SHOULD NEVER FEEL IN FEAR OF
YOUR LIFE, IT'S AN INTENSE
SETTING. YOU'RE SAVING LIVES.
YOU DO NOT WANT TO HAVE THAT
STRESS, THAT PRESSURE. HOWEVER,
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, VERY
WELL, WE YOU KNOW, WE COMMONLY
WE FALL INTO THE THEORY THAT IF
WE MAKE SOMETHING, IF WE ENHANCE
THE CHARGES OF SOMETHING, THAT
THAT BECOMES A DETERRENT. BUT AS
EVEN THE SUPPORTERS TESTIFIED
AND, AND THE AND THE AND FOLKS
THAT CAME TO MY OFFICE, THEY
ADMITTED THAT THIS IS OFTEN WHEN
A PERSON'S UNDER EMOTIONAL
DURESS, OR THEY COULD BE HAVING
A PSYCHOTIC EPISODE. I MEAN, WE
REALIZE NOW THAT BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF, LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES, THE LACK OF, EVEN
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONERS DÍAS
ERS ARE WHERE PEOPLE IN MENTAL
WHO ARE HAVING CRISIS OF MENTAL
HEALTH ARE BROUGHT AT. AND
PUNISHMENTS LIKE THIS ARE NOT
DETERRENCE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
WHO CAN USE NO JUDGMENT. AND TO
HAVE THE RESULT BE THAT WE HAVE
A PERSON WHO IS IN THAT KIND OF
PSYCHOTIC STATE, WHO MAY HAVE AN
UNDERLYING MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM
, THEN IN A JAIL FOR A YEAR,
WHERE WE KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW OUR
JAILS ARE THE MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES, WHICH WE KNOW
THEY'RE NOT. THEY CAN'T BE
THEY'RE NOT ADEQUATE TO BE, I
THINK YOU KNOW, THIS BILL, THE
ONE VERSION OF IT WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN FOR THE REASONS
BASICALLY DESCRIBING HOW ADDING
ENHANCED PUNISHMENT IS NOT A
DETERRENT AND THAT HE DIDN'T SEE
THE LOGIC FOR FILLING OUR JAILS
WITH PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS, EVEN THOUGH
HE, OF COURSE, LIKE ALL OF US,
DECRIED THE ANY, ANY VIOLENCE
THAT WOULD OCCUR TOWARDS A
HEALTH PRACTITIONER IN A
HOSPITAL SETTING OR AN EMERGENCY
ROOM SETTING, ANOTHER VERSION OF
THIS BILL WAS HELD BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN 2019, AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE AGAIN THE SUPPORTERS
FEELING LIKE, WHY SHOULD WE BE
LESS SUBJECT TO, A WHY SHOULDN'T
A PERPETRATOR AGAINST US HAVE
THE SAME TYPE OF, OF, CHARGES OR
CONSEQUENCES AS THE PERSON IN
THE COMMUNITY? I THINK THAT
LOGIC IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH, AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL IS, YOU
KNOW, GOT A LOT OF SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. IT'S WELL ON ITS
WAY. BUT I WOULD HAVE, I
SUPPOSE, IN WITHIN I THINK IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN WISE TO ADD SOME
, BUFFERS TO ADD SOME LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL THAT AT LEAST
ALLOWED A JUDGE TO CONSIDER IF
THE PERSON WAS IN A PSYCHOTIC
STATE, OR IF THE PERSON WAS, IF
THERE WAS THAT KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCE OF MENTAL DURESS
THAT COULD CAUSE IT DOESN'T
JUSTIFY THE HURTING OF ANYONE IN
THE HOSPITAL ROOM OR THE EMT.
DON'T GET ME WRONG, I DON'T WANT
ANYONE TO THINK THAT I AM
SOMEHOW JUSTIFYING. NO, I AM
NOT. BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
THESE KIND OF CIRCUMSTANCES, AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT'S THIS
COMMITTEE CALLED PUBLIC SAFETY,
THAT'S WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE. HOW DO WE
JUST PUTTING PEOPLE AWAY FOR
LONGER ISN'T NECESSARILY A
PUBLIC SAFETY OUTCOME. AND WHEN
WE CONSIDER MOST OF THE PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW, NOT EVERYBODY, MOST OF
THE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT GET CHARGED
UNDER THIS ARE GOING TO HAVE A
PUBLIC DEFENDER, AT LEAST IF
THERE WAS SOME KIND OF,
BUFFERING TYPE OF LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL, THEN IT AT LEAST WOULD
EQUIP A PUBLIC DEFENDER BETTER
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO DEFEND
THAT PERSON BECAUSE, RIGHT NOW,
WITH WHAT WE ARE DOING, IF WE
PASS THIS AND IT GETS SIGNED, IS
WE'RE JUST SAYING, YOU KNOW, YOU
PRETTY MUCH HAVE TO
AUTOMATICALLY GO TO JAIL FOR A
YEAR. AND I DON'T THINK WHEN WE
REALLY THINK ABOUT IT IS REALLY
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OUTCOME WE
NECESSARILY WANT. SO, I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT AND, THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU CAN
CLOSE WITH THAT. I JUST WANTED
TO JUST MAKE A POINT,
CLARIFICATION TO SENATOR,
REGARDING THOSE ISSUES REGARDING
MENTAL HEALTH AND PSYCHOTIC
ISSUES. SO THERE IS LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT THE JUDGE CAN USE
THAT UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
DEPENDING ON THE NATURE OF THE
INCIDENT. SO WITH THAT, I JUST
WANT THERE IS THAT FLEXIBILITY
IN THERE. AND WITH THAT,
OBVIOUSLY THIS HAS BEEN A
PROCESS OF ISSUES FOR DECADES.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE PANDEMIC, IT JUST
ELEVATED TO THE NEXT LEVEL, IN
THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH RELATED.
I TALKED TO FOLKS THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF THE FOLKS THAT
TAKE CARE OF US. RIGHT. AND I
THINK THIS IS JUST ONE STEP THAT
WOULD EQUALIZE PENALTIES IF
ALREADY OCCURS OUTSIDE OF A
HOSPITAL SETTING. IT SHOULD JUST
BE EQUAL INSIDE THE HOSPITAL AS
WELL. IT'S ALREADY THERE. SO
THIS IS JUST ONE WAY TO PROTECT
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS, EVERY
DAY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR SARDO.
CAN I JUST ASK ONE QUESTION IN
YOUR CLOTHES? YOU MENTIONED THAT
THERE WAS THAT LANGUAGE WHICH I
DID NOT SEE IN THE BILL. COULD
YOU TELL ME WHAT PAGE THAT IS IN
THE BILL OR WHAT'S SECTION, I
CAN GET I DON'T HAVE IT WITH ME
IN SENATE, BUT I CAN GET BACK
WITH YOU BECAUSE I. OKAY, AGAIN,
I COULD HAVE MISSED IT, BUT I
DID LOOK AT THE BILL CLOSELY,
AND I DID NOT SEE THAT. OKAY,
WE'LL LET THE CONSULTANT
ACTUALLY TAKE A LOOK. TWO
SECONDS. OKAY AND I MIGHT FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT IN THAT
CASE, BUT I DID NOT GET NOT DO
WE REOPEN ON THE FLOOR? IF THAT
IT'S THE CALIFORNIA RULES OF
COURT CASE 4.423. SO IT'S NOT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE BILL. IN THE
BILL, BUT THERE IS BECAUSE OF
THAT COURT CASE. RIGHT. WHICH IS
NOT THAT'S GENERAL LAW, WHICH I
APPRECIATE. HOWEVER, IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HELP IN ANY
PARTICULAR INCIDENCE. SO IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY GIVE A
PUBLIC DEFENDER MUCH FOR. ALL
RIGHT, WE HAVE A CLOSE WE HAVE A
MOTION. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE. AB 977 MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. I
CIERTO CIERTO I BRADFORD
BRADFORD I SKINNER WIENER. ALL
RIGHT THAT BILLS ON CALL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I BELIEVE
YOU ALSO HAVE OKAY. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN WITH AB
2120 AGAIN I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT I WILL BE PRESENTING
ANOTHER BILL, FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
MANY OF US HAVE BILLS TO PRESENT
, WE MAY BE STEPPING AWAY, AND
WE WILL HAVE OTHER FOLKS, CHAIR
THE MEETING AT THIS MOMENT IN
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 2120. I FIRST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL, AND WE
WILL BE TAKING ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AB 2120
CLARIFIES TRESPASSING PROVISIONS
TO EXCLUDE REPOSSESSION AGENCIES
AND PROTECT ITS EMPLOYEES WHILE
SEARCHING FOR COLLATERAL.
HOWEVER, REPOSSESSED ARE STILL
SUBJECT TO TRESPASSING LAWS OF
PRIVATE AND SECURE LOCATIONS.
WHEN A DEBTOR HAS FAILED TO
REPAY THE DEBT THE LEGAL OWNER
HOLDS, THE NOTE COLLATERAL MAY
ISSUE A REPOSSESSION ORDER. THE
LAW PROVIDES THAT UNDER THE
REPOSSESSION ORDER, A
REPOSSESSION AGENCY OR ITS
EMPLOYEE MAY COME TO THE
PROPERTY TO RECLAIM THE PURCHASE
THAT HAS FALLEN INTO DEFAULT.
BUT IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PROCESS, DEBTORS WILL OFTEN CALL
THE POLICE, CLAIMING THE
REPOSSESSOR IS TRESPASSING ONTO
THEIR PROPERTY AS A RESULT, THE
REPOSSESSOR GETS ERRONEOUSLY
ARRESTED, REQUIRED TO GO TO
COURT FOR TRESPASSING, ONLY FOR
THE CASE TO GET DISMISSED AT THE
HEARING. DUE TO THE REPOSSESSED
ARREST, THEY NOW HAVE A CRIMINAL
ARREST HISTORY FOR SIMPLY DOING
THEIR JOB. ÁP 2120 WILL CLARIFY
THE REPOSSESSES ARE NOT PUNISHED
NOR ARRESTED FOR TRESPASSING
WHILE SEARCHING FOR THE
COLLATERAL. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON AB 2020 TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO ARE SIMPLY DOING THEIR JOB.
HERE TO TESTIFY ARE MARCELLO
EGLI, PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
POSSESSORS AND ALSO DAVE
QUINTANA. THANK YOU. YOU'RE THE
PRIMARY WITNESS. GO AHEAD AND
YOU GOT ABOUT TWO MINUTES. YEAH,
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF. I JUST WANT
TO ACTUALLY THANK THE
CONSULTANT, ALEX, FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK ON THIS BILL, FOR ALLOWING
US TO COME UP WITH LANGUAGE THAT
ADDRESSED THE GOVERNOR'S VETO IN
A VERY ELEGANT MANNER. AND WITH
THAT BEING SAID, I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR THE PRESIDENT OF
OUR ASSOCIATION, MARCEL. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS MARCEL EGLI.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED POSSESSORS TO BRIEFLY
ADDRESS MISS SHEEHAN'S CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS BILL. AS FAR AS
THE CONSUMER DEBTOR, THEY
GETTING LITTLE OR RECEIVING NO
NOTICE REGARDING THE REPOSSESSOR
COMING TO REPOSSESS THE VEHICLE.
THE AVERAGE TIME FOR
REPOSSESSION TAKES ABOUT 90
DAYS. DURING THAT 90 DAYS, THE
CONSUMER, ALSO REFERRED TO AS
THE DEBTOR, IS CONTACTED AT
LEAST ONCE A DAY WITH EFFECTIVE
CONTACT DURING THE TIME FRAME OF
DELINQUENCY LEADING UP TO THE
REPOSSESSION. THÀNH. SOME
LENDERS ALLOW MORE THAN 90 DAYS,
GIVE OR TAKE A FEW DAYS LESS OR
MORE IF THEY'RE WORKING WITH THE
CONSUMER. IF THE CONSUMER HAS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THEM. BUT
THERE IS CONTINUOUS CONTACT,
EMAIL, TELEPHONE CALLS AND TEXTS
DURING THIS TIME. SO WHEN WE
ARRIVE AT THE SCENE, IT'S NOT A
SURPRISE TO THEM THAT WE'RE
THERE TO SECURE THE VEHICLE. AS
FAR AS SAFETY IS CONCERNED, THE
SAFETY REALLY LIES ON OUR SIDE.
I THINK IF YOU'RE TAKING, WHICH
IS AN INTIMATE TAKING, YES,
SOMEBODY'S VEHICLE, WHICH WERE
LICENSED TO DO OUR AGENTS ARE
ARE BONDED THERE. DOJ
BACKGROUND, FBI BACKGROUND
BEFORE THEY'RE EVER ISSUED A
LICENSE FROM THE STATE. IT'S
MORE DANGEROUS TAKING SOMEBODY'S
CAR FROM A GROCERY STORE, A
WALMART, LEAVING THEM STRANDED
WITH ALL THEIR BELONGINGS IN THE
CAR, CAR SEATS, ETC. WHEREAS IF
IT IS FROM THEIR HOME WHERE
THEY'RE CURRENTLY LIVING, THEN
ALL THOSE THINGS CAN BE RETURNED
TO THEM AT THE SCENE. OR THEY
CAN COME TO OUR FACILITY FREE OF
CHARGE AND PICK THOSE THINGS UP.
WE DO HOLD THOSE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR 60 DAYS. AS
FAR AS PREDATORY LENDING WITH
LENDERS AND DEALERSHIPS, I
BELIEVE IS THE MAIN PREDATORY
CONCERN OF MICHIGAN'S. WHAT I
READ IN HER OPPOSITION, THE
PREDATORY LENDERS THAT WE WORK
FOR, THE MAJOR BANKS, FORD MOTOR
CREDIT, CAPITAL ONE, ALLY BANK,
ARE NOT PREDATORY LENDERS. THE
DEALERS THAT SHE REFERS TO THAT
COMMIT THE PREDATORY LENDING,
MOST OF THEM PICK UP VEHICLES
THEMSELVES. THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
MOST OF THOSE REPOSSESSIONS DO
NOT COME TO US. IT'S THE MAIN
LENDERS THAT I MENTIONED AND
CREDIT UNIONS IN THIS SPACE. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS I CAN ANSWER
? NO, THAT WILL BE FINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE, ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AS A PRIMARY WITNESS, IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, COME TO
THE MIC. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I'M
ROSEMARY SHAHAN, PRESIDENT OF
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY AND, WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL MAINLY BECAUSE WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR ALTERCATIONS BETWEEN THE
OWNERS OF VEHICLES OR, OTHER
COLLATERAL THAT IS BEING
REPOSSESSED AND THE REPOSSESSES,
WHEN THEY'RE ON THEIR PRIVATE
PROPERTY. AND, THE BILL WOULD
GIVE A NEW EXEMPTION THAT HASN'T
EXISTED BEFORE FOR REPOSSESSED
CARS TO ENTER ONTO PRIVATE
PROPERTY, TO SEARCH FOR
COLLATERAL OR REPOSSESS THE
COLLATERAL AS LONG AS THEY LEAVE
THE PRIVATE PROPERTY WITHIN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME. AND
WE JUST FEEL LIKE IT'S REALLY
FORESEEABLE THAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO WANT TO DEFEND THEIR
PROPERTY FROM BEING SEIZED. AND
WE KNOW OF INSTANCES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE HAD DO NOT HAVE
ADVANCED NOTICE THAT THEIR
VEHICLE OR OTHER PROPERTY IS
GOING TO BE REPOSSESSED. AND FOR
SOME PEOPLE, WHEN THEIR CAR IS
REPOSSESSED, THEIR LIFE
BASICALLY FALLS APART. THEY LOSE
THEIR ONLY MEANS OF
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK TO GET
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL. AND OF
COURSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE UPSET
ABOUT THIS, AND, AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS AN ILL ADVISED
MEASURE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MA'AM. OKAY. AT THIS
TIME, WE'LL TAKE METOOS FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, ANYBODY
THAT WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS, ANYBODY ON THE DAIS WHO
WISHES TO COMMENT OR HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. OKAY.
MISS SKINNER. YEAH. THANK YOU.
LIKE OUR PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
HEARD, THERE WAS A BILL LIKE
THIS THAT WAS VETOED BY,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN, 21, 22
BECAUSE OF IT. THE BILL DID NOT
HAVE THE ITEM ABOUT REPOSSESSES
NOT ALLOWED TO GO INTO SECURED
OR LOCKED AREAS. I WANT TO KNOW
IF YOUR BILL CURRENTLY DOES IT
CONTAIN THAT PROVISION OR WAS IT
REMOVED? SO, IN OTHER WORDS,
DOES IT CONTAIN THE PROVISION
THAT, THAT THIS DOES NOT APPLY
TO THEM GOING INTO A LOCKED OR
SECURED AREA? I KNOW THAT THE
CONSULTANT ADDRESSES THIS VETO
IN THE, IN THE, THE TESTIMONY
AND AS WELL AS THE INFORMATION,
BUT ALSO DEFER TO, TO MARCEL FOR
SOME OF THAT, DATA. IF YOU COULD
. AND THE SPECIFIC QUESTION IS
WHETHER THE BILL CONTAINS THAT,
PROVISION THAT PROHIBITS THEM
FROM GOING INTO THE SECURED OR
LOCKED AREA. YES, MA'AM. WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO GO INTO A LOCKED
AND SECURED AREA. YOU'RE
ANSWERING THAT GENERALLY. BUT
THIS BILL IN ITS PREVIOUS
VERSION ELIMINATED THAT CLAUSE.
AND I WANT TO KNOW IF THE
CURRENT IF THE ONE BEFORE US HAS
THAT IN IT OR NOT. YES. I
APOLOGIZE, THAT WAS MY ANSWER. I
WASN'T CLEAR, BUT YES, IT DOES
NOT INCLUDE, LOCKED AND SECURED.
SO IT DOESN'T EXEMPT US FROM
THAT. IS THAT YOUR QUESTION? AM
I ANSWERING YOU CORRECTLY? I
DON'T KNOW. SO. SO YEAH. SO WE
PUT BACK THIS IS THE AMENDED
LANGUAGE AND IT PUTS BACK THE
REFERENCE TO THAT WHICH
PROHIBITS THEM. OKAY. SO YOU
HAVE IT IN KHÓ OKAY. SO THE
CONSULTANT JUST, CLARIFIED THAT
THE AMENDMENT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE MOST RECENT, WELL,
IT'S AN AUTHOR'S AMENDMENT, I
GUESS, BUT, DOES PUT THAT BACK
IN THAT THE YOUR PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL WOULD HAVE
ALLOWED THE, POSSESS OR TO GO
REPOSSESSOR TO GO INTO A SECURED
OR LOCKED AREA AND NOT BE
CONSIDERED TRESPASSING. AND NOW
THIS VERSION HAS IT WHERE YOU
CANNOT CORRECT FOR PROHIBITS
THAT FROM GOING TO LOCK. OKAY,
SENATOR. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS, WHILE I SYMPATHIZE
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING THEIR
POSSESSIONS, RIPA'S TEST,
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT. THEY
BREACHED THEIR CONTRACT, AND A
LOT OF TIMES, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE TRY TO, ONLY
THINK ABOUT REPOSSESSIONS OF THE
POOR PERSON WHO'S GOT THEIR
LITTLE CAR, AND THEY VERY
DEPENDENT ON THAT. BUT A LOT OF
TIMES THOSE ARE NOT WHAT, WHAT
ARE THE TARGETS OF REPOSSESSION?
BECAUSE SOMETHING HAS TO BE
VALUABLE ENOUGH TO REPOSSESS.
OTHERWISE THE PROCESS COSTS MORE
THAN THE POSSESSION OF WHAT
THEY'RE REPOSSESSING. AND THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. SO THOSE
AREN'T NECESSARILY WHAT THEY'RE
GOING AFTER, WHAT THEY'RE GOING
AFTER ARE VEHICLES, THAT THAT,
SOMEBODY WAY OVEREXTENDED
THEMSELVES AND SOMETIMES THEY'RE
EXOTIC VEHICLES THAT ARE WORTH
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
. AND, AND SO THEY NEED THE
TOOLS TO DO THEIR JOB SAFELY.
AND BECAUSE THOSE CONFRONTATIONS
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN, WHETHER,
THEY ARE, IN ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
OR ON PUBLIC PROPERTY, IF YOU
COME OUT TO GROCERY STORE AND
YOU GOT A BAG FULL OF GROCERIES
AND THE REPOSSESSION OF THEIR,
YOU THINK THERE'S NOT GOING TO
BE A CONFRONTATION? OF COURSE
THERE IS, AND THAT'S WHY, YOU
KNOW, THE JOB OF A REPOSSESSION
IS PRETTY DANGEROUS, I WOULD
IMAGINE. AND I THINK THEY, THEY,
THEY, THEY DO THINGS IN A MANNER
WHERE THEY TRY TO MINIMIZE THAT
AS MUCH AS THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ALLOW THEM, TO WHICH IS THEY'D
RATHER HAVE NO CONFRONTATION AT
ALL. AND BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THE PROPERTY THAT DOES NOT
ANYMORE BELONG TO THAT PERSON
WHO IS NOT PAYING FOR IT OR DID
NOT PAY FOR IT, IS NOT THEIR
PROPERTY, AND THEY'RE JUST
TAKING IT BACK. AND IF THIS LAW
MAKES IT EASIER FOR THEM TO DO
THAT AND A LITTLE BIT SAFER,
THEN I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH IT.
AND SO, SO WITH THAT, I CAN I
YOU GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. HOW
ABOUT A VOTE? THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WHY DON'T YOU
HAND ME THE GAVEL WHEN YOU CAN
MAKE THE MOTION? AND WITH THAT,
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT, I'LL
MAKE THE MOTION. THANK YOU, ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. OKAY THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED. YOU'VE MADE
YOUR CLOTHES? YES. WE'LL DO A
ROLL CALL, MAYBE 21, 20. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SEYARTO A
SATO I BRADFORD SKINNER. I
SKINNER I WIENER. THE BILL IS ON
CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. WHY DON'T YOU
PRESENT? I'M GOING TO GIVE BACK
THE GAVEL TO THE VICE CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING. MEMBER. WELCOME
AND, YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I WANT TO FIRST THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE. AND WE DO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS, TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1788,
WHICH ALLOWS COUNTIES TO
ESTABLISH MENTAL HEALTH,
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAMS FOCUSED
ON ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS. THE PREVALENCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AMONG
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS HAS
SKYROCKETED TO 20% IN 2010, TO A
STAGGERING 53% IN 2023. IN
SHORT, THIS MEANS MORE AND MORE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE COMING INTO
OUR COUNTY JAILS HAVE SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS TO FULFILL
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
REHABILITATION AND REDUCE
RECIDIVISM, WE MUST DEVELOP
EFFICIENT PRACTICES TO ASSIST
INDIVIDUALS GRAPPLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS WITHIN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM, JUST A PERSONAL
NOTE. I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT OUR ORANGE COUNTY COUNTY
JAIL AND SEE SOME OF THE UPDATED
PRACTICES THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ENGAGING WITH IN ORDER TO, MAKE
SURE THEY'RE MEETING THE NEEDS
OF SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THEY'RE SEEING, VAGUENESS
IN EXISTING LAW HAS HAMPERED
EFFORTS, INCLUDING THE LACK OF
AUTHORIZATION TO FACILITATE THE
SHARING OF CRITICAL INFORMATION
BETWEEN ENTITIES. AB 1788 ALLOWS
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAMS TO SHARE
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION TO
EXPEDITE MENTAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS AND FACILITATE
SERVICES WELL INCARCERATED AND,
UPON RELEASE. MOST IMPORTANTLY,
AB 1788 INCLUDES SAFEGUARDS TO
PROTECT CONFIDENTIALITY K¾T
ENSURING THAT SHARED INFORMATION
IS USED SOLELY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES WITH NO IMPLICATIONS IN
THE INDIVIDUAL'S LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS. WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE AND THE
SPONSOR OF AB 1788 IS MR. RAY
GRANOFF, CHIEF OF STAFF OF
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF CORONER
DON BARNES, GREAT. JUSTICE
THING. OKAY. WELCOME, SIR. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE. THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. AND, PARTNER
WITH ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK-SILVA,
WHO REALLY HAS BEEN AN
EXCEPTIONAL PARTNER WITH US ON,
ON THESE ISSUES, AS MANY AS YOU
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, 2020 SAW
THE PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL
210, WHICH ALLOWED FOR INCREASED
INFORMATION SHARING BETWEEN
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAMS TO
ASSIST THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. SOME OF THE
INFORMATION SHARED INCLUDE
INCLUDED HEALTH INFORMATION,
MENTAL HEALTH INFORMATION, LAW
ENFORCEMENT DATA, AND SOCIAL
SERVICES INFORMATION. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS NOT RECIPIENT OF
THE MENTAL OR MEDICAL HEALTH
INFORMATION, WHICH IS CAREFULLY
PROTECTED BY HIPAA. HOWEVER
BEING ABLE TO SHARE OUR DATA
WITH PROVIDERS ALLOWED FOR
BETTER SHELTER PLACEMENT AND
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE. BEING ABLE
TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION LED TO
THREE EXPECTED OUTCOMES BETTER
QUALITY OF SERVICE DELIVERY,
INCREASED ABILITY TO MATCH
BETTER SERVICES TO THE CLIENT.
REDUCE COSTS BY DECREASING
DUPLICATION OF SERVICES, POST
COVID, CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION IT
SERVES. OUR ORANGE COUNTY
POPULATION JUMPED FROM 22% TO
45. FOR THOSE WITH AN OPEN
MENTAL HEALTH CASE, THOSE
NUMBERS ARE EVEN MORE STRIKING
CONSIDERING THE AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION HAS DECREASED BY 50%
SINCE COVID, WE HAVE ALSO SEEN A
SHARP INCREASE IN THOSE
EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER IN ORANGE COUNTY,
APPROXIMATELY A THIRD OR 900
INMATES ARE RECEIVING MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT TO HELP THEM
OVERCOME OPIOID ADDICTION. LIKE
MANY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS, THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN NUMEROUS
PROACTIVE STEPS TO ASSIST THE
JAIL POPULATION IN EXPERIENCING
BOTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. THIS
INCLUDES SPECIALIZED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HOUSING UNITS AND
INCREASE IN LPS BEDS, CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING FOR ALL
OUR STAFF AND NEW RANCH AND
PROGRAMS. AB 1788 IS THE NEXT
PRO PROACTIVE STEP IN CREATING A
MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAM, AND WE
JUST APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SIR, FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WHO WANTS TO BE A LEAD WITNESS?
IF NOT, WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION. IS ANYBODY
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AS
A LEAD WITNESS. IF NOT, WE'LL
TAKE THE METOOS FOR BOTH
OPPOSITION AND FOR PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT THE BILL. JUST COME UP
TO THE MIC, STATE YOUR NAME, THE
ORGANIZATION, AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY, AS WELL
AS THE CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES, BOTH IN SUPPORT.
ALSO, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS,
CURRENTLY IN SUPPORT WITH THE
MINOR AMENDMENT AS OUTLINED IN
OUR LETTER. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS? GO
AHEAD. SENATOR SKINNER, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. I THE I, THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT HERE IN THIS
BILL, THE EVIDENCE THAT WHAT
PERCENT OF OUR JUSTICE INVOLVED
PEOPLE ARE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS KIND OF SPEAKS TO THE
PREVIOUS BILL. BUT THIS ONE, OF
COURSE, IS FOR THE
INTERVENTIONS. WHEN THE PERSON
IS IN JAIL VERSUS PREVIOUS PRIOR
TO THEIR GETTING TO JAIL. AND I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE DONE WE
MEANING THE LEGISLATURE AND OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN TRYING TO,
INCREASE OUR, RESPONSE, PROVIDE
FOR CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT IS
NON PUBLIC SAFETY, NON ARMED
PUBLIC SAFETY, RESPONDING TO
MENTAL HEALTH TYPE CIRCUMSTANCES
VERSUS LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND THAT
I HOPE WILL HELP. AND, MEANING
WILL HELP IN TERMS OF HAVING
FEWER OF OUR POPULATION THAT IS
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FROM ENDING UP IN JAIL.
AND THIS OF COURSE, IS ONCE THEY
ALREADY ARE IN. BUT, I THINK
THIS IS CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH,
BECAUSE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OUR
BUDGET DEFICITS, HAVING A PERSON
IN JAIL FOR A YEAR IS A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN PROVIDING THEM
GOOD MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR, ARE IN
CARCERAL FACILITIES, WHETHER
STATE PRISON OR JAIL ARE FAR
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN AS EXPENSIVE
AS GOOD MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
IS IT IS CHEAPER THAN JAIL TIME.
SO, BUT ANYWAY, YOUR BILL IS
ABOUT ONCE THEY'RE THERE, BUT I
THINK AT LEAST IT DOES ADDRESS
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE MANY, MANY
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
IN OUR FACILITIES. AND WITH
THAT, THAT'S WHY I WILL SUPPORT
IT. AND THAT'S WHY I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE IT. OKAY. AND THEN I WILL
JUST ADD ON TO THAT, THAT,
SOMETIMES THAT'S WHERE THE ONLY
PLACE YOU CAN GET A HOLD OF
SOMEBODY THAT'S HAVING THIS AND,
AND THEREFORE BEING ABLE TO GET
THEM TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY TREAT THEM. BUT WHEN
THEY GET THERE, WE NEED THE
TREATMENT. SO IT'S A PIECE OF
THE SYSTEM THAT IS BROKEN AND
NEEDS WORK. AND I THINK YOUR
BILL GOES A LONG WAYS TO DOING
THAT. AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT. AND YOU MAY CLOSE,
THANK YOU, SENATORS. I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS IS PERSONAL TO ME,
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW, THAT I, IN
FACT, HAD A BROTHER THAT WAS
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND AS
MANY OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
INTERFACE WITH OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM, THEY OFTEN DO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
ADDICTION ISSUES. AND I KNOW
THAT IF WE HAD HAD THIS BILL, OR
A FORM OF THIS BILL WHERE THERE
WAS A INTERFACING, WELL, THEY
WERE INCARCERATED AND AFTER AND
BEFORE ALL OF THOSE PIECES
REALLY NEED TO BE THERE, HE
WOULD STILL BE ALIVE TODAY, AND
I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT THE WORK
THAT IS BEING DONE WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED, WHETHER IT'S IN,
IN OUR JAIL SYSTEM OR EVEN
PRISON THAT THAT FOLLOWS
AFTERWARDS BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE MISSING THAT LINK, WHERE
WHEN THEY LEAVE, THE
INSTITUTIONS THEY ARE MANY TIMES
THEY FLOUNDER AND, AND ARE NOT
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE. AND BY BEING
ABLE TO BUILD THIS, SYSTEM
AROUND THEM THAT CAN INTERFACE
WHILE THEY'RE IN AND OUT, I'M
HOPING WE'LL MAKE A VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE. AND WITH THAT, I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER
. GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ÁP 1788. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO JUDICIARY.
WAHAB SATO I, SATO I BRADFORD
SKINNER I SKINNER I WIENER. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON
CALL. AND WITH THAT, WE HAVE NO
OTHER AUTHOR. YOU COULD LIFT THE
CALL ON CONSENT. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND LIFT THE CALL ON
CONSENT. THANK YOU. CURRENTLY 3
TO 0. SKINNER Ã SKINNER. I
WIENER. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO LEAVE THAT OPEN UNTIL SENATOR
WIENER GETS BACK. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A SHORT RECESS UNTIL, WE
GET SOME AUTHORS. SO IF YOU'RE
AN AUTHOR AND THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME BECAUSE YOU'RE THE LAST
ONE.
HERE. WE'RE GOING TO CALL US
BACK INTO ORDER. THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE IS RECONVENING
SO THAT WE MAY HEAR THE LAST OF
OUR BILLS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US. YOUR
COMMITTEE, AND WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL
TO BRING ABOUT MORE TRANSPARENCY
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHEN THEY
HAVE SETTLEMENTS OR PAYOUTS
RELATED TO, POLICE MISCONDUCT.
WE KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, CLEVER
REPORTERS FIND AND PUT IN A
LOCAL NEWSPAPER, BUT TOO OFTEN
THE PUBLIC IS SHIELDED FROM
THESE, THESE SETTLEMENTS. AND
THIS IS TAXPAYER MONEY. SIMPLE
AS THAT, YOU KNOW, SOME
JURISDICTIONS HAVE TO ISSUE
BONDS THROUGH WALL STREET TO PAY
SOME OF THESE SETTLEMENTS. AND
THIS IMPACTS THE ABILITY TO PAY
FOR PARKS AND, YOU KNOW, POLICE
SERVICES AND FIRE AND OTHER
GENERAL SERVICES IN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
DOLLARS ARE, ARE SPENT IN
JURISDICTIONS, AND THE PUBLIC'S
WELL AWARE, WITH THAT, WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS, TO REDUCE COSTS AND
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRACY, WITH ME TODAY ARE
TWO WITNESSES FROM ACLU
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF
THE FIRST WITNESS WILL COME TO
THE MIC, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ALICIA
BENAVIDEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 1725 POLICE
MISCONDUCT COST CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR AND THESE SETTLEMENTS
RESULT IN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
PAYING OUT SIGNIFICANT TAX
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE USED TO
BETTER INVEST INTO THE
COMMUNITY. FOR EXAMPLE, IN 2022,
A SAN DIEGO FEDERAL JURY AWARDED
5 MILLION TO AN INNOCENT PERSON
WHO WAS ATTACKED BY A POLICE
DOG. IT HIT ON THE HEAD AFTER HE
COMPLIED WITH OFFICER REQUESTS.
ALL WHILE HIS HANDS WERE
RESTRAINED BEHIND HIS BACK. AND
IN 2023, A MAN WAS AWARDED 1.3
MILLION BECAUSE HE WAS TASED
JUST BEFORE POLICE DOG TORE A
CHUNK OFF OF HIS CALF. THE MAN
WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIME, AND JUST LAST MONTH HERE
IN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO, A
SETTLEMENT FOR 3 MILLION
INVOLVING A WOMAN WHO WAS STRUCK
IN THE FACE BY RUBBER BULLET AND
BLINDED IN ONE EYE DURING A 2020
PROTEST AGAINST POLICE BRUTALITY
. UNFORTUNATELY, THE TOTAL SUM
OF SETTLEMENTS AND THE
ASSOCIATED OFFENDING CONDUCT ARE
NOT EASILY ACCESSIBLE, AND WHILE
TAXPAYERS PAY FOR THESE
SETTLEMENTS, THE PUBLIC OFTEN
WILL ONLY HEAR ABOUT THE
SETTLEMENTS FROM NEWS OUTLETS.
IF AT ALL. THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS IS
DIFFICULT TO FIND AND FREQUENTLY
REQUIRES EXPENSIVE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT LITIGATION. CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO FILE
CIVIL SUITS OR CLAIMS AGAINST
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR MISCONDUCT.
USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS THAT
RESULT IN DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY, AND THE LAW ALSO
STIPULATES THAT OFFICERS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING THESE
SETTLEMENTS. INSTEAD, THE
SETTLEMENTS TYPICALLY COME FROM
GENERAL FUND OF THE JURISDICTION
INVOLVED. THAT MEANS CITY AND
COUNTY BUDGETS ALLOCATE FUNDS TO
THEIR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THEY'LL BE FINANCIALLY
LIABLE FOR WRONGDOING YEAR OVER
YEAR. AB 1725 MERELY ENSURES
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING
REQUIRING ENTITIES TO POST
FINANCIAL DETAILS ABOUT POLICE
MISCONDUCT, SETTLEMENTS,
JUDGMENTS AND ON THEIR WEBSITES.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW HOW THEIR GOVERNMENT SPENDS
THEIR TAX DOLLARS BY REQUIRING
MUNICIPALITIES TO PUBLICLY POST
FINANCIAL DETAILS OF THEIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF FORCE
SETTLEMENTS AB 1725 PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
PUBLIC, AND FOR THESE REASONS,
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
SPEAKER, PLEASE. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON, FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1725. NOT LONG AGO
, I SERVED ON THE SOLANO COUNTY
CIVIL GRAND JURY, FOR TWO YEARS.
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE LOOKED AT
WAS THE USE OF FORCE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR COUNTY. AND
HOW MUCH TAXPAYER MONEY WAS PAID
OUT TO SETTLE LAWSUITS ALLEGING
THE USE OF EXCESSIVE FORCE BY
OUR LOCAL AGENCIES. I HAD NEVER
KNOWN AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPOKE ABOUT, OTHER THAN IN
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES, WHAT KIND OF
SETTLEMENTS AND LARGE PAYMENTS
WERE MADE BY THE CITIES AND
SOLANO COUNTY IN SUCH LAWSUITS?
I WAS SURPRISED AT THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY, OUR MONEY THAT WAS SPENT.
I WONDERED AT THE TIME WHY THERE
WASN'T A TRANSPARENT MECHANISM
TO ALLOW THE CITIZENS TO SEE HOW
MUCH OF THEIR MONEY WAS BEING
SPENT DUE TO THE USE OF
EXCESSIVE FORCE. IT SHOULDN'T
TAKE A CIVIL GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATION AND SUBSEQUENT
REPORT, OR A PUBLIC INFORMATION
ACT REQUEST TO MAKE THIS
INFORMATION FULLY PUBLIC. I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE DIFFICULTY FOR
OUR AVERAGE CITIZEN TO NAVIGATE
THE FILING OF A PRA. KPDA IS A
LONG STANDING HISTORY OF
ADVOCATING FOR POLICE
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY,
AND ACCESSIBILITY. WE AGREE THAT
AB 1725 PROVIDES IMPORTANT
PUBLIC ACCESS TO POLICE
ACTIVITY, EASY ACCESS TO
CRITICAL INFORMATION REGARDING
POLICE SETTLEMENTS AND JUDGMENTS
. THIS IS A MUCH NEEDED
CORRECTION TO THE OPAQUE
INFORMATION AND SECRECY THAT
CURRENTLY SHROUDS MUCH OF THIS
INFORMATION FROM PUBLIC VIEW. AB
1725 WILL PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
K¾T BY PROVIDING THE PUBLIC WITH
A CLEAR WAY TO LEARN ABOUT THE
ACTIONS OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND HOW MUCH OF OUR TAXPAYER
MONEY IS BEING SPENT, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE ANYBODY ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
THESE ARE METOO'S, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS, JULIANA VOIGTS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. REGRETFULLY
IN OPPOSITION, WE HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING TO THE OFFICE AND
COMMITTEE STAFF ABOUT THIS BILL.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT ADDRESS
A COUPLE OF OUR CONCERNS
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION ON THE
BILL, HOWEVER, WE STILL HAVE NOT
SEEN THE LANGUAGE, AND ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT'S TO BE
ADDRESSED IS THOSE CITIES WHO
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT. THERE'S ABOUT 155
CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN
POLICE DEPARTMENT. SO WE BELIEVE
THOSE CITIES SHOULD ONLY HAVE TO
REPORT ON, THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
THEIR OWN JURISDICTION, WITH
THEIR OWN WITHIN THEIR OWN CITY,
JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND,
CITIES ARE SUED. UNFORTUNATELY
OVER A VARIETY OF ISSUES, FROM
MINOR CAR ACCIDENTS, SLIP AND
FALLS, CODE ENFORCEMENT,
PROPERTY DAMAGE, AND THE ALLEGED
CONDUCT OF POLICE. THOUGH THE
PARTICULAR FACTS OF ATTORNEYS
HANDLING ANY GIVEN CASE MEANS
THERE WILL BE VARIANCES FROM
TIME TO TIME IN GENERAL, ALL
CITY LITIGATION AND SETTLEMENTS
ARE HANDLED THE SAME. A CLAIM IS
RECEIVED, IT IS ASSESSED IF NEED
BE. IS ASSIGNED TO AN ATTORNEY
FOR HANDLING, AND THAT ATTORNEY
WOULD ENGAGE IN WORKING UP THE
CASE. FOR FORMAL SETTLEMENT
NEGOTIATIONS. SOME CASES MAY GO
TO TRIAL, BUT OFTEN BECAUSE OF
FINANCIAL REASONS, THESE
LAWSUITS ARE SETTLED AND AS
NOTED IN OUR FIRST LETTER WE
SENT TO THE AUTHOR, 95% OF CIVIL
CASES ARE GENERALLY SETTLED OUT
OF COURT, AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE SENSITIVITY OF
POLICE CASES, CITIES GET SUED ON
A VARIETY OF CASES. SO ISSUES.
SO THESE ARE OFTEN HANDLED THE
SAME WAY AS, AS MANY OTHER CASES
AS WELL. IT MAY SOUND LIKE AN
EASY THING TO POST ALL POLICE
SETTLEMENTS. THESE REQUIREMENTS
ARE STILL AN UNFUNDED MANDATE,
SO WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS, OUR MAIN CONCERN
STILL REMAINS ABOUT THIS
UNFUNDED MANDATE AND THE FACT
THAT ALL THIS INFORMATION IS
READILY AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC,
ALL OF THIS, ALL OF THE CITY'S
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS, POLICE OR
OTHERWISE, ARE ALREADY PUBLIC
RECORD AND ARE READILY
ACCESSIBLE BY ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THROUGH A CITY COUNCIL
AGENDA. FOR EXAMPLE, THEY'RE ALL
AGENDIZED ON A CITY COUNCIL
AGENDA. YOU CAN ALWAYS SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU WANT, AND
ARE LIKEWISE ALREADY, AS
MENTIONED BY THE SUPPORTERS,
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. SO THEREFORE WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THE BILL IS
NECESSARY. THANK YOU. AND WE
URGE YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I WAS A LITTLE BIT I
GOT A LITTLE BIT LOST IN OUR
PROCESS THERE, ARE YOU ALSO A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS?
CORRECT. OKAY, THEN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
FAITH BURGESS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES, I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
AUTHOR, STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR BEING GENEROUS WITH
THEIR TIME TO HEAR OUR CONCERNS.
WE DO HOPE TO CONSTRUCTIVELY
BUILD ON THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY SUPPORTS
THE PRINCIPLES OF TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WAS
NOTED BY MY COLLEAGUE, BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT SINCE THE 1970S,
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN UNWILLING TO PROVIDE
INSURANCE TO PUBLIC AGENCIES,
AND SO PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE USED
THE JPA MECHANISM TO EFFECTIVELY
SELF-INSURE FOR THIS LIABILITY.
AND NOT FOR PROFIT JPA'S. THIS
MODEL IS USED BY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO MANAGE THESE PAYMENTS. JPA'S
ARE NOT INSURANCE WITH LARGE
CAPITAL RESERVES ALLUDED TO
THROUGHOUT THE BILL'S CURRENT
TEXT AND THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION
OF THIS ISSUE. THESE CLAIMS ARE
FULLY FUNDED WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SCARCE DOLLARS. THE
JPA ARRANGEMENT ENABLES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EFFECTIVELY
SELF-INSURE. OUR CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IS THE REALITY THAT
THE PLAINTIFF LAWYERS USE AWARDS
AND KNOWN SETTLEMENT VALUES TO
ANCHOR JURIES OR NEGOTIATE
HIGHER SETTLEMENT VALUES. WITH
THIS INFORMATION AS THE NEW
FLOOR. THIS UPWARD TREND HAS
RESULTED IN A SUBSTANTIAL
DIVERSION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS AWAY FROM PUBLIC
SERVICES AND TOWARDS LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS WITH PLAINTIFF
ATTORNEYS COMMONLY TAKING 30 TO
50% OF SETTLEMENTS AND AWARDS IN
THE SPIRIT OF TRANSPARENCY, WE
WOULD LIKE MISREPRESENTATIONS
ABOUT INSURANCE VERSUS JPA'S
CORRECTED WITHIN THE BILL. WE'D
LIKE TO KNOW HOW MUCH PUBLIC
MONEY IS GOING TOWARDS ATTORNEYS
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO KNOW WHY
THE STATE HAS BEEN OMITTED FROM
THE CURRENT VERSION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY, NOW IS THE TIME FOR THE
METOOS. SO ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO ADD ON, AS OUR AS A
VOICE FOR EITHER AN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT CAN COME UP, STATE
YOUR NAME, THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT, AND WHETHER YOU'RE
SIMPLY WHETHER YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. THIS IS NOT
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU. DONOVAN
HALL WITH CATALYST CALIFORNIA
MORNING, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR. ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO COME UP? OKAY. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS AT
THIS TIME. SENATOR SKINNER, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR BRINGING
IT. I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
ADDITION TO OUR, OUR EFFORTS IN
RECENT YEARS TO BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO, TO OUR,
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. SO I THINK
IT'S A GOOD BILL, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT. I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE IT. OKAY. SO I
GUESS THAT BRINGS IT TO ME, YOU
KNOW, I WAS REALLY INTENDING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BUT IN, IN
LOOKING AT IT AND LISTENING TO
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS,
YOU KNOW, THEY KIND OF BRING UP
A GOOD POINT, IT JUST SEEMS A
LOT OF THIS IS ALL AIMED AT JUST
ONE AGENCY, THE POLICING AGENCY.
AND WE HAVE ALWAYS, AS YOU KNOW,
A MEMBER OF A CITY COUNCIL,
MYSELF, WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN ABLE
TO AND HAD TO REPORT OUT
WHENEVER WE HAD SETTLEMENTS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THIS. SO IS YOUR
EFFORT TO MAKE THE INFORMATION A
LOT EASIER TO PUT OUT THERE?
BECAUSE IF THAT'S THE EFFORT,
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION IS WHY
NOT FOR EVERYBODY, INCLUDING
THIS BUILDING? BECAUSE IT'S ALL
PUBLIC MONEY. AND IF WE'RE
REALLY INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE
THE PUBLIC KNOWS HOW THEIR
PUBLIC MONEY IS BEING SPENT ON
LAWSUITS, THEN, AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO OUTSIDE OF THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. WE HAVE, THEN IT SHOULD
APPLY TO EVERYBODY. SO MY
QUESTION WOULD BE WHY WOULDN'T
IT? WELL, I'M OPEN TO THAT. ON
ANOTHER BILL. MAYBE YOU AND I
CAN OFFER THAT BILL NEXT YEAR. I
WON'T BE HERE NEXT YEAR, BUT YOU
CERTAINLY CAN, YOU KNOW, AS, AS
SENATOR SKINNER MENTIONED, THIS
IS A TRANSPARENCY ISSUE, AND
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS, BIPARTISAN ON,
ON, EXCESSIVE FORCE, POLICE
STANDARDS, DE-ESCALATION, THÀNH,
AND BY ALL MEANS, YOU KNOW,
INCIDENTS HAVE GONE DOWN, POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ARE GETTING BETTER.
AND THE MORE THE PUBLIC KNOWS
HOW MUCH IS BEING SPENT ON THESE
SETTLEMENTS, THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO DEMAND THAT THEIR
POLICE DEPARTMENT, YOU KNOW,
IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICES TO TRY
TO BRING ABOUT BETTER OUTCOMES.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
THIS IS NOT THAT COMPLEX. AND
I'M I'M KIND OF CONFUSED ABOUT
THE ARGUMENT, THE OPPOSITION,
THERE'S THREE THINGS. THERE'S
ONE, THE SELF-INSURED CITIES,
THE CONTRACT CITIES. AND THEN
YOU KNOW, WHY PUT THIS UP THERE.
IT'S A BURDEN TO PUT IT UP
THERE. BUT IT'S ALREADY UP. IT'S
ALREADY AVAILABLE ANYWAY, SO
IT'S ALREADY AVAILABLE AND IT'S
EASY TO GET. IT SHOULDN'T BE
THAT HARD TO SPEND, YOU KNOW,
THREE HOURS ON THE 1ST OF
JANUARY TO GO BACK AND PUT THE
WHATEVER THE ONLY PROBABLY MOST
JURISDICTIONS HAVE A COUPLE OF
THESE SETTLEMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR TO PUT THEM UP ON THEIR
WEBSITE, LIKE THEY PUT UP
HUNDREDS OF THINGS ON THEIR
WEBSITES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. SO
I DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW HOW
MUCH OF A BURDEN IT IS, YOU
KNOW, I THINK IT'S TRANSPARENCY.
THIS HAS BEEN A BIPARTISAN BILL
IN YEARS PAST. IT HAS, YOU KNOW,
I THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN ALL GET BEHIND AND
MAKE SURE WE ARE SPENDING OUR
TAX DOLLARS AND THE PUBLIC KNOWS
ABOUT IT IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ANSWER. AND
YOU KNOW, I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT
, THE TRANSPARENCY, ISSUE AND,
PEOPLE KNOWING, IT JUST I ALSO
AGREE WITH THAT. IT SHOULDN'T
STOP HERE. AND IT'S, IT'S KIND
OF SAD THAT IT DOES, AND SO, I'M
STILL A LITTLE BIT ON THE FENCE,
BUT I GUESS I BETTER MAKE UP MY
MIND QUICK. SO WITH THAT, I'LL
ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE, ENJOY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS AND
WORKING WITH YOUR COMMITTEE TO
CLARIFY SOME THINGS. AND, AND WE
WILL WORK WITH THE, THE OTHERS.
AND I'M STILL NOT CERTAIN ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION FROM THE CONTRACT
CITIES. I'LL CONTINUE TO LISTEN
TO THAT AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN, YOU KNOW, ACHIEVE AN
OUTCOME THAT'S FAIR FOR
EVERYBODY. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. GREAT. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND GO AHEAD
AND CALL ROLL SB 1725. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SEYARTO
NOT VOTING CIERTO. NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
WIENER. WIENER. AYE ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD. I'M SORRY
THAT BILL HAS, TWO VOTES AT THIS
TIME. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD IT
OPEN AS WE WILL FOR THE OTHER
THINGS UNTIL THE OTHER MEMBERS
CAN COME ON AND ADD ON. Ó
WIENER. LET'S DO THAT, YOU KNOW
WHAT? WHY DON'T WE OPEN THE ROLL
FOR THE EVERYTHING. EVERYTHING
IS MISSING. YEAH. ALL RIGHT. AB
977, A MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER. I I'M
SORRY. THERE WAS THREE 3 TO 0 AS
WELL. YEAH OKAY. I WAS GOING TO
STAY OFF. I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
CHANGE IT TO A NO. OH, YEAH. AND
VOTING NO. YOU CAN'T GO TO NOT
VOTING FOR ME. THIS HAS TO GO.
NO OKAY I WAS GOING TO STAY OFF.
I'M SORRY I ACCIDENTALLY VOTED
OFF. I'M GOING TO GO TO A NO,
OPEN TO SUPPORTING IT IF THERE
ARE CHANGES. OKAY THAT'S NOT THE
CURRENT FORM. OKAY. IT'S OUT
THREE TO 3 TO 1. OKAY. THAT BILL
IS OUT 3 TO 1. OKAY AB 1788,
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO JUDICIARY. WHO'S NOT HERE?
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0. WIENER I
WIENER I STILL WAIT FOR WAHAB.
IT'S ON. THAT BILL WILL STAY ON
CALL CONSENT CALENDAR WIENER I
WIENER I. YEAH. YOU'RE GOOD. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. OKAY AB
2120. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. WIENER I WIENER I. THAT
HAS THREE VOTES. IT WILL STAY ON
CALL. THAT'S IT, THAT'S IT.
OKAY, OKAY. YEAH WHICH, BY THE
WAY, WE SHOULD.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK
FROM RECESS AND LIFT THE CALLS.
HOLD ON. LET ME PULL IT UP. IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED TO APPENDS. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD. I OKAY, THAT STAYS ON
CALL. YEAH. OKAY. SO WHAT. THAT
STAYS ON CALL. ARE WE WAITING
FOR WAHAB? OKAY OKAY. WE'LL, PUT
THAT BACK ON. CALL MY AB 1788
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO JUDICIARY. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I PUT IT BACK ON CALL
AB 2120. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. ON CALL. PUT IT
BACK ON CALL. THAT'S IT. THAT'S
IT FOR YOU. THAT'S IT. OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK INTO
RECESS UNTIL, SENATOR WAHAB
RETURNS. THAT'S ON THE WHAT?
YEAH YOU VOTE ON.
OKAY. WE'RE BACK IN FOR LIFTING
CALLS. OKAY, SO THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS BACK ON, AND I
JUST WANT TO LIFT CALLS. AB
1725, THE MOTION WAS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. WAHAB.
WAHAB, I WAS OUT. THAT BILL IS
OUT. AB 1788. MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0. WAHAB. THAT AYE. WAHAB. AYE
THAT BILL IS OUT AB 2120. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 4 TO 0. WAHAB. AYE.
AYE FIVE ZERO. THAT BILLS OUT.
THAT'S IT. THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
OKAY I HAVE YEAH. SO THE FULL
PACKAGE IS OUT. CORRECT. SO
THAT'S IT. ALL RIGHT. AND SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS NOW ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.